in unserem universum stimmt etwas nicht
nach unserem aktuellen wissenstand
dürften galaxien eigentlich nicht
existieren wir sollten gar nicht hier
sein irgendetwas umgibt alles bewegt
alles aber ist dabei total unsichtbar
und detektiert
wir nennen es dunkle materie aber lasst
euch davon nicht auf den falschen pfad
führen nur weil wir dem unbekannten
einen namen gegeben haben heißt das noch
lange nicht dass wir auch wissen was es
ist sie macht 85 prozent aller materie
aus aber woraus sie wirklich besteht das
weiß keiner es gibt allerdings ein paar
spannende theorien und genau um die geht
es in diesem video
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist make something
[Musik]
mit wissenschaft wollen wir unsere welt
verstehen und vorhersagen darüber
treffen können dafür werden zuerst
theorien aufgestellt die danach
bestätigt werden müssen aber eine der
wichtigsten theorien der physik können
wir bis heute nicht so richtig
bestätigen eigentlich müssten wir
nämlich genau vorhersagen können wie
sich galaxien in relation zueinander
bewegen schließlich verstehen die
gravitation und kennen die masse dieser
galaxien aber in der praxis beobachten
wir etwas komplett anderes
die bewegungen sind konfus und gehen
gegen fast alles was hier in
berechnungen erwarten würden und das
ganze zerbricht nicht erst seit gestern
die köpfe von forschenden
1933 wurde diese entdeckung erst mal nur
belächelt 30 jahre später war man sich
aber sicher hier stimmt irgendwas nicht
denn man hat beobachtet dass galaxien um
sich selbst schneller rotieren als man
es erwarten würde bei den planeten die
unsere sonne umkreisen verhält sich das
eigentlich ziemlich logisch je weiter
sie entfernt sind desto langsamer
bewegen sie sich aber galaxien tun genau
das gegenteil das kann man sich wie
einen spenden trichter vorstellen das
loch in der mitte des trichters stellt
das gravitations potenzial von zb
unserer sonne da und die münze ist unser
planet die erde je mehr die münze jetzt
der mitte kommt desto schneller muss sie
sich bewegen um nicht direkt in das loch
zu stürzen bewegt sich die münze ich
jedoch am rand der bahn kann sie sich
relativ langsam bewegen würde sie sich
hier so schnell drehen wie in der mitte
dann würde sie einfach aus der bahn
fliegen und genau so ist das bei den
sonnensystemen in der milchstraße sie
bewegen sich alles so schnell dass sie
eigentlich raus fliegen müssten aber sie
tun es nicht warum
ok nächster vergleich für die
milchstraße stellen wir uns das ganze
jetzt wie ein kettenkarussell vor die
planetensysteme sind die passagiere und
die gravitationskraft sind die ketten an
denen die sitze befestigt sind es muss
immer ein gleichgewicht zwischen
gravitationskraft und radial kraft
bestehen sonst fliegt man entweder in
die rotationsachse rein oder aus dem
karussell raus beides nicht so optimal
da wir uns aber schneller bewegen als
gedacht müssen uns stärkere ketten auf
unserer bahn halten das heißt
irgendetwas was auf die gravitation
einfluss hat wie aber anscheinend nicht
sehen detektieren oder irgendwie sonst
wahrnehmen können hält uns in der bahn
und das ist dunkle materie diese materie
ist wie eine wolke die alles durchdringt
unsere komplette galaxie ist voll von
dunkler materie und diese muss aus ganz
anderen teilchen bestehen als die die
wir bisher kennen ansonsten hätten wir
sie schon längst gesichtet gerade weil
sie rund 85 prozent unserer gesamten
materie im universum ausmacht das heißt
es gibt ungefähr 6,5 mal mehr dunkle als
normale sichtbare materie hier in diesem
studio bei euch zu hause alles was ihr
jemals gesehen oder angefasst habt macht
nur 15 prozent aller materie aus den
großteil aller materie kennen wir also
gar nicht und es kommt noch viel
schlimmer wir wissen immer noch nicht
was genau dunkle materie jetzt
eigentlich ist woraus besteht sie woher
kommt sie und wie reagiert sie auf
normale materie
glücklicherweise haben wir zumindest ein
paar anhaltspunkte zum beispiel
interagiert dunkle materie nicht normal
das heißt sie imitiert und absorbiert
kein licht nehmen wir zum beispiel mal
mein t shirt die teilchen aus denen man
t shirt besteht reflektieren das licht
und so können wir erkennen dass es zum
beispiel rot ist durch die dunkle
materie hingegen gehen lichtteilchen
einfach durch so dass wir sie nicht
erkennen können aber das ist noch nicht
alles auch elektromagnetisch zeigt sie
keine wechselwirkung man kann also nicht
mal schnell einen magneten hinhalten und
sammelt damit dunkle materie ein und wie
man es beispielsweise bei magnetischen
stoffen machen
wobei das auch nicht ganz richtig ist
wenn wir jetzt morgen einen weg finden
ein super magnetfeld zu erschaffen dann
würde dunkle materie sich eventuell
zeigen aber dazu später mehr also um das
einmal kurz zusammenzufassen was genau
dunkle materie jetzt wirklich ist und
worauf sie besteht ist ein großes
mysterium dass die wissenschaft schon
lange beschäftigt ein mysterium dessen
auflösung vermutlich mit einem
nobelpreis belohnt wird
guten abend meine damen und herren wir
verlosen heute als hauptgewinn diesen
wunderschönen nobelpreis hier die
quizfrage dazu woraus besteht dunkle
materie zu so einem verlockenden angebot
sagt man natürlich nicht nein und
deswegen gibt es einige teilchen
theorien die hier bereits ins rennen
gegangen sind teilchen nummer eins wilms
dunkle materie könnte aus rims bestehen
rim steht für really interesting messe
portugal so schwach wechsel wirkendes
massereiches teilchen und da schwimmt es
wmt nicht so leicht über die zunge geht
bleiben wir hier erst mal im englischen
wir erinnern uns noch mal an die dunkle
materie wolke überall hier ist dunkle
materie in dieser theorie also
vielleicht auch jetzt gerade vips laut
berechnungen wäre das um genau zu sein
eine kaffeetasse und
ungefähr 235 uns in einem menschlichen
körper und als wäre dunkle materie nicht
kompliziert genug gibt es natürlich auch
noch ganz viele erklärungsansätze wir
beschränken uns in diesem video hier
aber aus zeitgründen auf extra
dimensionale teilchen das sind teilchen
die in einer extra dimension einen
impuls haben und diesen impuls nehmen
wir in unserem dreidimensionalen raum
als masse war ganz vereinfacht gesagt
die sims machen in einer extra dimension
etwas was wir in unseren dimensionen als
dunkle materie wahrnehmen und dieser
extra dimensionale impuls sorgt dafür
dass wir zum beispiel nicht aus der
milchstraße fliegen was ziemlich
praktisch ist was ist eine extra
dimension gute frage ist natürlich
eigentlich noch mal eigenes video wert
aber ganz kurz zusammengefasst stellen
wir uns vor wir sind ein seiltänzer auf
dem seil können wir entweder vor oder
zurück gehen es gibt keine anderen
richtungen wir leben also in einer
dimension
während wir aber kein mensch sondern zb
ein käfer auf dem seil dann hätten wir
eine dimension mehr in der wir uns
bewegen können wie schnell der kiefer
dann um das seil läuft das stellt den
impuls dar den wir in unserer welt als
masse wahrnehmen klar so red aber wie
könnte man jetzt überprüfen ob brems
tatsächlich hinter der mysteriösen
dunklen materie stecken nun dafür geht
man zum beispiel mal ganz fix an szenen
schiesst in ganz großen maschinen ganz
kleine teilchen aufeinander und misst
was passiert die idee dabei ist dass
durch den zusammenprall von zwei
teilchen dunkle materie entsteht da
dunkle materie aber nicht mit materie
wechsel wird verlässt sie unerkannt das
experiment und die forschenden bemerken
dass dann im detektor in form von
fehlender energie aber leider hat man
noch nichts in diesen messungen gefunden
was auf dunkle materie hindeuten würde
man benötigt anscheinend noch höhere
energien um die wilms falls sie dann
überhaupt existieren zu erzeugen und
auch an anderen forschungseinrichtungen
wie beispielsweise auf der iss wurden
leider noch keine games gefunden das ist
aber gar nicht so verteilt wie man denkt
denn die wissenschaft hat noch weitere
teilchen theorien in petto
bevor wir zu diesen anderen teilchen
theorien kommen kommt hier mal ein
kleines mini behind the scenes video das
hier ist handels der editor dieses
videos dass ihr gerade guckt er
schneidet gerade daran und es ist noch
gar nicht fertig jack russel von die
metaebene wie viel arbeit steckt schon
drin und wie viel arbeiten muss da noch
eingehen bis es fertig ist heute ist
freitag ist seit montag dran und bis es
fertig ist sonst locker bis acht stunden
also zwei wochen toure arbeiten das ist
nur der schnitt des videos werden wie
vorher auch noch recherchiert und das
skript geschrieben ist meistens auch so
ungefähr zwei wochen also mindestens
einen monat an arbeit nur damit einen
doktor watson video dass hier jede woche
raus kommt entsteht und das ist
tatsächlich nicht nur viel zeit sondern
auch ziemlich viel geld für uns denn wir
wollen ja alle auch das essen und miete
zahlen und genau deswegen gibt es pedro
león wo ihr uns direkt unterstützen
könnt wenn ihr unsere videos so gut
findet dass sie das gerne machen möchte
das hat auch vorteile für euch dann
könnt ihr zum beispiel videos früher
gucken vor allen anderen zwei drei tage
vorher ließen wir die für die pages oder
ihr werden im abspann als page supporter
genannt mit eurem namen und wenn ihr
ganz bestimmtes werk auswählt werde ich
euch sogar persönlich danken in einem
video uns hilft es auf jeden fall sehr
denn wir sind ja nicht ganz so abhängig
von werbepartnern kooperationspartnern
sondern können dann die videos machen
die wir wirklich machen wollen deswegen
dankeschön an alle leute die uns auch
paige unterstützen hier auch schon mal
ein dankeschön und natürlich gleich
nochmal im abspann und ihr fehlt aber
weiter mit teilchen nummer zwei der
aktionen
teilchen nummer zwei aktionen damit das
universum in seiner jetzigen form
überhaupt existieren kann mussten
materie und antimaterie nach dem urknall
in unterschiedlichen mengen entstehen
sonst hätten sie sich einfach komplett
gegenseitig zerstört eine dafür
notwendige bedingungen ist die
sogenannte verletzung der cp symmetrie
und achtung jetzt wird s mal kurz
kompliziert bei dieser cp symmetrie
verletzung hat man vorher gesagt dass
sich physikalische zusammenhänge und
gesetzmäßigkeiten in einem system ändern
wenn man die ladung von teilchen umkehrt
und die raum koordinaten spiegelt um die
verletzung der cp symmetrie zu beweisen
braucht ein neutronen ein elektrisches
dipolmoment
dieses hat man jedoch noch nicht
gemessen was manche forscher also
gemacht haben ist diesen wert künstlich
auf null zu setzen das hat wiederum
anderen forschenden gar nicht gefallen
um diese willkür zu erklären hat man
also ein neues physikalisches feld
eingeführt dieses können wir uns wie
eine halfpipe vorstellen das axiom
teilchen in diesem feld wird zum
beispiel von diesem skateboard er
repräsentiert lassen wir das skateboard
jetzt in die halfpipe rollen dann wird
es am ende immer am niedrigsten punkt
ankommen und so wird auch unser teilchen
in unserem feld immer den niedrigsten
wert anstreben in unserem fall 0 wenn
ihr euch jetzt fragt was denn genau
eigentlich ein physikalisches feld ist
und was ein teilchen ihr kennt ja
vielleicht das elektromagnetische feld
die teilchen die dazugehören sind die
photonen und wie das elektromagnetische
feld die photonen als teilchen hat hat
auch unser neues feld die aktionen als
teilchen
aktionen gibt es wie sand am meer 10
hoch 16 aktionen kommen in einem würfel
zucker vor wenn es die masse der dunklen
materie erklären soll dieser dunkle
materie kandidat muss laut theorie
leicht mit dem elektromagnetischen feld
interagieren und kann sich dabei zu
einem photon umwandeln und photonen die
können wir messen genau das macht das
forschungsteam als experiment in hamburg
sie versuchen mit licht durch eine wand
zu scheinen das klingt erstmal im
erstmal total irre aber es ergibt beim
genaueren darüber nachdenken schon sinn
unser foto wird durch ein starkes
magnetfeld dazu verleitet sich in ein
aktion zu transformieren dieses durch
quer die wand und wandelt sich danach
wieder zurück in das photon welches wir
dann auf der anderen seite der wand
detektieren können man will also licht
auf eine wand scheinen und erwartet dass
am anderen ende wieder licht dabei
herauskommt aber auch hier das gleiche
wie bei dem sneijder hat man dabei noch
nichts gemessen einerseits weil es viele
schritte im prozess verlangt wovon jeder
leider ziemlich unwahrscheinlich ist
andererseits weil man um die
wahrscheinlichkeit zu erhöhen stärkere
magnetfelder benötigt die mit dem
momentanen stand der technik bei der
noch nicht realisierbar sind
[Musik]
ok so richtig können wir momentan
einfach noch nicht beantworten was genau
jetzt dunkle materie ist aber was
wichtig ist es muss nicht zwingend ein
entweder-oder sein es können sowohl die
rems als auch die aktionen gemeinsam
dunkle materie sein das wie wo wann was
der dunkle materie bleibt also erstmal
ein rätsel aber hoffnung liefert
beispielsweise die verbesserung des
teilchenbeschleunigers am cern welche ab
2024 geplant ist um höhere energien zu
erreichen außerdem wird an der
realisierung des future circular
collider gearbeitet der noch mal weitere
möglichkeiten bereit hält vielleicht
können wir also schon in wenigen jahren
mit weiteren bahnbrechenden ergebnissen
rechnen die unser verständnis der
jetzigen realität vollständig verändern
werden wenn es etwas neues gibt dann
machen wir natürlich sofort an wieder
darüber in diesem sinne abonniert gerne
den kanal um nichts zu verpassen und
bleibt wie immer neugierig patrick
teilchen nur 1